starting with
it too funny
hey we're live oh Donald's back and
we're live
howdy animation
very good sir somebody was late I mean
well I was originally I was in the
little zomb's room wait which way do I
go what's the Little Dom's room
descent however you're comfortable I can
fix it all right there we go oh we are
here
okay wait all right no we can fix it
though it's fine this is good wait ah
[ __ ] how do I do oh [ __ ]
oh this is too funny wait do I go to the
oh no I'm messing everything up
no it's fine we're cool here we go
wait wait wait I'm coming
it's Bobcat wait what I'm sorry I'm
trying to not you what are you doing oh
Bobcats
God damn it you're still Bobcat shut the
[ __ ] up
I hate this
are you okay Neil Alvin I like the way
you say poppy hey welcome back everybody
uh it's our second episode that's crazy
I'm watching the World Cup while
watching your stream there who who are
you picking who's playing today
I can't remember who's playing today
it's called football right
I'm in America I I just call it soccer I
was gonna I was gonna correct you it's
like it's soccer I was like no it's not
it's football
it's Croatia Belgium Belgium's gonna win
hey oh [ __ ] who's the Rex says who's the
cool dude on the far right that's the
weave King hey Rick it's not the whip
King well one day one day one day okay
what are we talking about today gents
the anime in question
what are we talking about have you guys
seen a parasite has anyone seen in the
audience have watched the made in Abyss
episode if you guys haven't watched it
you can watched it uh after we finish
streaming after do not watch it right
now
that would be rude don't do that 100
[Laughter]
[Music]
I thought the plan today was the
parasite thing wasn't it we're talking
about parasite is not out yet
damn it well exclusive you know footage
for the the viewers you're welcome oh
[ __ ]
not even made an abyss reverse I put it
I made a thumbnail for uh for summertime
rendering so it's not even made it a bit
I [ __ ] up
oh [ __ ] I sent you a text saying yo we
talking about XYZ and you didn't say
anything else I didn't see that I messed
up it made it a bit season two's out uh
summertime rendering part one is out
uh we separated to two parts so if you
notice that the part ended in the middle
of the season that's probably why and of
course true Griffin just spoiled it uh
we are gonna release parasite part two
this weekend oops uh don't I'm sorry it
would be like a little nugget you know
that's what you get it's out made it a
business out Bobcat it's out it's out
oh so cute
I don't even watch anime at this point I
just watch your videos thank you I don't
even watch the animation I edit ing
yes you do I do I'm a nerd all right
how's it going guys
how do you guys uh yeah how do you guys
enjoy the summertime rendering it's a
new anime that came out this season or
2022 this year oh really yeah the season
it was pretty new
yeah that the video is doing pretty good
thank you all for loving it so much
appreciate it greatly
but I thought it was interesting like
you know in the Audio I talked about it
was like it's kind of like Groundhog Day
meet you know Dom talked like edge of
tomorrow and it's interesting kind of
how the whole looping thing but what I
liked is how each time he dies he is his
Mulligans start getting less and less so
it's like eventually you better figure
this out are you really gonna die you
know so I thought that was pretty cool
the thing is he's a lot smarter than
Edge of Tomorrow honestly if you've seen
at you tomorrow he's dying until he it's
like a it's like a puppy he keeps doing
the wrong thing every time
I read some movie Theory I can't
remember but like it showed like how
many times you actually have to go
through it I can't remember but like
yeah Tom Cruise is a dumbass in that
thing she went through it like thousands
of times or something oh but I used to
love that movie it's a good movie it's a
good it's a good one it's a good it's an
anime movie it's an anime live action
movie maybe we can put that in our in a
how to beat I don't know I don't know
maybe it's an anime live action movie we
should maybe we should go one more
Cruiser it sucks that they haven't made
an anime out of it the anime uh the
artist who did the manga was the guy who
drew Death Note uh really oh yeah it was
good it was like a it was one book one
thick ass book but yeah it's a good
anime if you guys haven't seen it oh no
it's a good manga it's a good movie to
watch they did change it a little bit to
fit like a western kind of plot stuff so
they switched some stories around but
yeah uh Dom someone's saying it's a damn
nice suit man Bobcat uh Bobcat it's
literally my only one but like because
nobody wears suits anymore I want to
wear a suit for the special occasion
should I grab a suit right now just to
wear it with you but I don't want to you
should oh what if we did a suit day
where we all wore suits
we'll wear a suit next time all right
I'll wear a suit next time just remind
me if I have to fun fact for Halloween I
literally just wore a suit and I put
like two paints of dot on my neck and
I'm like I'm a vampire victim who
dresses well
it's just the extra comma it's like I'm
a vampire victim who dresses really well
uh it was great good everyone understand
we were trying to talk him out of it
like no do something else you know be
creative he's like I'm gonna be I'm
gonna be the weed killer I'm just gonna
wear a suit and a crown that's how it
works yeah I was thinking of getting
like a high my name is and then you put
like weave King like uh I'm gonna
because no one really knows see hey
Bobcat yeah way to Suit Day is actually
a good idea
it's starting to annoy me that whenever
you say Bobcat sometimes you met me
sometimes
today
but I've never celebrated Halloween
it's all right Bob I don't really
celebrate it I just go out to meet
friends Tom just likes to be addressing
means of women
dress up
uh link kind of guy you know if you ever
I like that I like that name dress up
darling I'm just a dress-up I'ma use it
it's a good it's a good anime it's a
good manga too my dress oh is that anime
yeah it's like about a girl who wants to
be
who's oh yeah super big into cosplay
cosplay yeah the guy who's super into
like a Japanese art of like drawing old
school dolls so he does the makeup of a
doll and then it's like dresses it up
it's like it's like old school
traditional so it's not really uh so the
way he practices it he practiced with
this girl who drew like to make it more
lifelike and to make it flow and like
making clothes and cosplay it's very
cute it's a very cute story and she's a
very best Girl Material if you don't
know why not me if you haven't seen it
it's good uh
uh you don't get candy from strangers
shocked I just got that out of a white
van that lives outside my house guys
when I was a kid it's crazy I don't
remember uh five years of my life
oh you're in Morocco cool oh you don't
celebrate Halloween
what is Halloween
it's really just for like an opportunity
to go out and party for most people
honestly like I don't think nearly
Thailand we don't really you know
celebrate it's just you know
there's a lot of stuff behind it you got
like historical things where it's some
people related to like these Witch
Trials way back when that happened you
know over here in the states and uh
you know like wicking rituals and things
some people talk about like various
Puritan like church stuff and how that
kind of was a part of it and there's
there's a big history behind Halloween
but generally nowadays it's like you go
hang out uh
get candy just hang out like Dom said
you just kind of hang out with people
dress up have fun that's more or less
what it's like at least here in the
states for me
um
I mean I is it is it from the states
because I do know that it's also like
what is it Theo
the The Day of the Dead also in Mexican
yeah culture so I don't know if it's
like interlocking and interweaving with
everything oh that would be interesting
uh anyone know that if there's any
connections between
because I just recently watched Coco
again
that was cute
oh cool never started Halloween
Christmas lunar Valentine okay
Bobcat don't you change a goddamn thing
your name is perfect
though hair play look at that guy very
hot
um one of my favorite anime very quickly
and you guys introduced me to it yeah
yes honestly as a non-web we have to
become the king of weebs made in the
base was probably one of my
self-appointed
country of one
country I've only done
that's right I'll take it wait you still
have your burger king crown
yeah hold up go get it
uh uh you guys haven't seen we one of
them we have a sponsor with
and we had fun with it and Dom
uh don't play the weed King and oh right
and Griffin play I'm a court jester it
was really funny yeah and if it actually
ate mud bro
I was like kind of obsessed listen I'm a
committed individual listen like I live
in the middle of nowhere truly like
middle of nowhere and I was like well
crap I don't have time to buy like a
peasant or a surf outfit so you know
what I'm gonna do I'm gonna grab some
stuff tear it up roll around in some mud
that I quite literally did do
and smeared mud on my face and I'm like
oh go check it out just if not the video
but for the sponsor part it is a very
fun one uh you guys also introduced me
to Maino [ __ ] oh which one yes his name
is
nice I caught that I caught that nice
hey he's asking for the watch trick
where's the watch oh [ __ ] okay okay now
I know I don't have it with God okay you
okay I'm gonna write it down now
it's not here with me right now but I'm
gonna look next time I don't wear it
that much but yeah okay I'm gonna bring
it I'm gonna bring it weebs forgive me
forgive me I'm sorry
uh remind him next time you can always
follow Dom he's only on Instagram uh
harass him over there at Dom jeswell oh
yeah Horizon to remind him that he's he
needs to do the watch trick bring up
it's a really good trick guys it's a
really good it's simple but it's good
but I feel like I've built up too much
hype but now I'll I'll show it I'll show
I'm putting a reminder putting her for
everyone who doesn't know who we are uh
Griffin over to my left
hello left uh you did it uh dogs on the
right uh he's our head writer only
writer we don't have any other writer so
I don't know what I say he's the only
one yeah uh and there's Ryan Reynolds
yeah I know and I also do the editing
so yeah so we are a trio a Triforce of
uh oh Triforce I love the Zelda
reference
totally caught that
very good uh yeah Dom doesn't know
anything about games or even Henry oh I
I played Outlast you know that was a
good game
one day we'll do how to beat Outlast
how to beat the psychiatric ward in
outlast one they will do it
people are hashing you up dumb they're
like the watch trick he keeps forgetting
to watch look I put a reminder I'm very
forgetful for most things I put a
reminder it's coming next week weebs I
promise next week yeah better my life
experience good job guys thank you by
far favorite Channel yes thank you
that's good but yeah let's go talk about
summertime render because we just made
it it was such a fun anime who's your
favorite character and why is it uh I
can't remember her name no blonde girl
uh isn't it was it oh gosh Lucio ushio
right yeah who's your favorite
um
I would say a glasses girl Top Notch
glasses Girl bathroom girl oh but she
also changes the glasses guy Midway oh
spoilers but yeah it's a whole thing
that's true like a split personality
yeah some one body kind of thing let's
see uh me I like
I actually like well okay so if you
don't know we like to do abbreviations
or nicknames for various anime people
either just because we want to or we
just feel lazy we don't want to say the
guy's name but
um so OG Shadow you know like basically
the right hand man to the shadow God I
actually kind of like that character oh
he's a good that's kind of my favorite
actually yes
uh yeah I kind of like that the redhead
guy keeps getting brought a lot stronger
along in there
and every time they have to remind tell
him he they do it twice in the in the
first part of the move uh the anime the
one that we did but it was really funny
because he keeps like oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
Shadows are real and then the next one
is that so you're alive [ __ ] yeah yeah
that's true that's true bro that anime
was hard to [ __ ] right it was like
the first one main dude wakes up he gets
off the boat he talks to the girl he
goes to a funeral but then he dies and
he goes back to the beginning and I'm
like oh wait here I already wrote this
can I like do I cut it you know do I cut
down the sentence and then each time I
have to cut down every you know all his
actions got really hard and I was like
does it even make sense anymore you know
it does apparently it's everywhere it's
people liking the video hell yeah weaves
I love you guys what let me see it
glasses girl could go get
what could get it too uh it was bad bad
as in bad isn't good I think ah yeah
that's right that's what I think that
mean too I wasn't sure glasses curl is
topped here glassy girl is overpowered I
mean
and they also put him that she has
powers it's like it's crazy
oh that's right yes
that came out of nowhere all right
that's a weird way of saying that she
has powers but not saying that she has
powers yeah
I tried so hard to explain
oh Toby 0076 is someone who watched the
entirely made Abyss I was kind of
annoyed and sad when you didn't say oh
magicka's name once in the video ah okay
fair play fair play I'm sorry yeah
that's the problem sometimes I've
started to you should have okay it's
good you you started watching us now in
the beginning I would literally just
Name all the characters just random Ash
except like the main three people
everybody else would just get random ass
names and I'd like yeah I'm trying not
to do that and like you know research
like name the the fun can we watched our
earlier videos all right here's the
here's the T here's some gossip here's
some background Dom keeps saying purple
hair like a purple hair girl into pink
hair girl he keeps naming them oh my
gosh it was like blue hair guy and he
has green hair it's like what the [ __ ]
yeah I don't know how I did that I don't
know what happened there it's like
sometimes it happens it's like no like
what are you doing
the color and some and in our earlier
videos when we were trying to establish
how we name people Griffin also has a
problem also where he over pronounces
words
I like to like go so hardcore like if I
know how to pronounce the name in Jeb or
like the Japanese name it'll be like
just too much it was like oh
that could be really weird
right like
like kotoro I'd be like kotoro it's like
I don't need to do that
I don't need to do that
after I told you it's like if someone's
name it's like if we ever do full metal
Alchemists which we'll probably never do
because it's action maybe we should do
um I mean there's a lot of spooky stuff
in it though there's a lot of spooky
stuff and we probably could make we
could probably make a human much better
than Edward and Elric and Edward and
Edward and Alphonse but you know what
I'm saying is that I explain it to him
that if there's an English name
character and you and in the anime if
you watch the sub version he said it
was like are you gonna say it Eduardo
are you gonna say Edward like
it's like
that's how they said it the Japanese
dubbed actor you know yeah but the name
is in England
oh my God Bobcat stop jumping on
Bobcat's neck
yeah be nice all right are you guys ever
gonna do about one piece if you guys are
able or give us an arc that fits how to
beat anime because we I figured out I
forgot but some people have helped me
figure out uh Hunter Hunter
uh I want to figure out one piece
what could be a good one piece Arc it
would be really hard because of the
scale but I feel like the Marine Ford
you know were white beard fights the
white green HQ yeah
you know what would be cool is the I
can't remember his name
uh
the bag the pirate guy the big pirate
they're all Pirates what I'm talking
about the graveyard they're the
graveyard boat where the big guys like
always goes she
they first met uh the guy who's
skeletons uh all full Scouts I can't
remember his name too he said Frankie uh
one piece people let me know help me uh
wait hold up the wee King wants to know
give me a 10 second run down to one
piece sell it to me one piece is uh a
pirate named Luffy wants to go on an
adventure to find One Piece One Piece is
a a treasure that was put down by Goldie
Roger in the middle of an island
somewhere and it's their his journey
finding his crew like Luffy finding his
crew and fighting all all Pirates to get
that one piece of treasure and that's
basically and they have problems and
they have like they have good powers
powers are cool
nice Bobcat gotta go all right do your
thing Bobcat thank you I'm just saying
hi to your cousin thank you all right me
uh who said this neonicon the suit will
be a regular thing trying to be Suave
and it gives me an excuse to wear the
suit so ow it's Gekko Moria Greco Moria
gekkomoria yeah that was such a good
breakfast
the Thriller Barker
uh the Thriller bark Arc that could be a
thing
uh because that's kind of spooky in a
way because people keep like there's
like a death life and death kind of
situation
uh Brooke as the Brooke is the skeleton
guy the skeleton oh that that guy's
funny I love it
this isn't a fortnight stream it's the
weeb stream so just you know keep your
finger off the exit buttons and keep
watching what do you mean you're not
gonna do uh a floss for the fortnite
Stream
uh okay yeah the floss you don't know
the flaws move what the [ __ ] you Boomer
okay we've gone off track so we were
talking about summertime rendering what
we liked about it what didn't we like
about summertime rendering
uh what didn't we like I think it could
what didn't we like uh I don't know I
kind of liked it I actually read the
um I read the Manga like three years ago
charcoal comic if you're gonna say a all
the time I'm gonna I'm gonna ban you
've been naughty jarco stop spamming I'm
gonna ban I'm gonna give you uh a
timeout can you time out on
put yours we're gonna give it a warning
we'll see what he does if he keeps we're
timing you are hello
there we go
all right timed out I kind of read the
Manga and I really like the manga and I
figured that they were gonna
they were gonna actually make an anime
probably soon because it's so
interesting and so dense in a way that
they probably was able to do it do you
guys have any like any stuff that you
guys don't like about the anime uh the
anime
at all let's see
I kinda wasn't a fan of uh
what was it
like I thought it was kind of cute by
the same respect like kind of was
thinking like ushio's character I was
gonna like
I don't know something bad I just
wasn't feeling it so much
I know I felt like maybe she could have
had more complexity to her you know like
yeah
blonde hair check yeah like
she's always like I love like she was
like kind of like you know never lets
herself get down she's always super
optimistic always very you know upbeat
and everything but I was just you know
I would like to maybe have seen a little
bit more layers or depth she was kind of
extremely bubbly way too positive all
the time
Mr Downer
what was um what was on redhead guys
um the dad the doctor no yeah but like
we find out that the dad has been
supplying the the Shadows like food or
whatever
a Twist remember yeah he was kind of
part of the hole though yeah I kind of
wouldn't mind seeing like a little bit
more into that I don't know like or
showing the dad do something in the
beginning that we don't think is evil
but then later on we're like ah [ __ ] he
did the thing at the beginning but we
didn't you know what I mean you know
maybe if they did a prequel for
summertime rendering and you could see
how the dad of like you know the the
corner how he met the shadow God and how
that whole thing played out after we
could start like as a really goody two
shoes you know fight for good or
whatever and then like we see like the
morph you know kind of like Joker but
like anime weeb stuff that was sick
let's see question how do you get so
famous in such a short period of time I
know let's talk about anime and then
we'll uh that's what I just sent those
oh that's right if you guys have any
questions you can uh shoot uh in the
chat and while I'll compile them and
we'll talk about it soon
we're still trying to figure out our
system we're gonna figure out how to
test them and figure it out bro about
that anime y'all talking about and uh in
the video y'all say Shadows have been on
the island a long time but that little
girl is the first to be taken over
what's up with that uh the Shadows
entity was uh has been in the island for
so long but the girl the first the
little girl was the first one to be
taken over and be actually
uh like
uh the first one that was like the first
Domino to fall before the island was
taken over and that's why what's his
fate I can't remember his I can't I'm so
bad with names main guy Capital blue
that's why
uh because like were they just around
they were around and the old the the
doctor guy and then they were like
probably trying to grow their power and
then they're gonna take over or you can
watch the part two guys you can just
watch part two probably gonna release
somewhere next year
fingers crossed
fingers crossed it's next year
uh
but yeah it's like it's crazy I think
it's one of my favorite animes this year
I'm also saying this because I haven't
seen uh chainsaw man
uh I haven't seen chainsaw man so tell
me it's probably the best anime of the
year but yeah oh [ __ ]
we probably should do it chainsaw man
also
um
is it at 12 12 episodes
uh I don't know is it 12 or is it 24
Griffin I don't remember
you don't understand how stressful it is
when I get these 24 episode things that
I have to condense I'm like it's a lot
of information and then I got Anime
there's already so much [ __ ] that I have
to take out right but you give me like a
24 episode thing it's a lot of stress so
hopefully chainsaw man is uh 12. all
right then we'll do Full Metal Alchemist
again you have to do it in one episode
it's 56 episodes
hell no bro you [ __ ]
oh that's funny would you like to try uh
to try to beat IRL I can 100 percent
uh
uh I can beat [ __ ] Sao
I can do sword art online I'll glitch
that [ __ ] through
uh do you guys have it I feel like what
about you guys
what anime would y'all like to try to be
in real life ooh
um
uh is that Crown gonna be for sale I
will not be for sale unfortunate I'm
gonna frame this and put in like I
should actually make a crown merch
plushie oh that's too funny or like a
weed King thing like a weeb king
have a little crown with like a pen or
something you could be like holding a
pen or something oh yeah
oh my gosh literally like during all my
friends birthdays I'll be like here you
go a plushie of the weave king that's so
shitty I'm sick here we go
oh my merch here you go you don't even
you don't even get it for free you get
it on your birthday Get Wrecked [ __ ]
or like you know you're at the bar and
you're trying to impress people it's
like I'm gonna flush you guys let's talk
about it
yeah yeah but in terms of an animated
real life would I be um I feel like uh
I feel like I probably do actually
pretty well with Goblin Slayer Goblin
Slayer yeah
they made it so easy bro Goblin Slayer
that was the cutest anime in the world
bro no it's it's so crazy
we're just going on these little like
mini adventures and there was talk of
the goblin army but I'm like hey no
Goblin Army bro it's like that comes way
late they're just on these little random
Adventures killing like these little
goblins and [ __ ] sounds like a fun time
fun time uh I like that it's a mini
Adventure I like that the main guys only
kind of have one goal right it's like I
[ __ ] hate Goblin uh goblins is like
pests that if you let them faster it
will [ __ ] destroy yeah
and I find that really cool and I enjoy
it's enjoyable I haven't I haven't uh
watched the
the rest of the month I haven't read the
rest of the manga I think you get a bit
more they're trying to World build
currently so it's kind of boring
currently oh sure yeah Global Gabby uh
this Crown is from Burger King well it's
from Burger King but Dom blocked out it
with yellow tape I guess
40 minutes
you took you 40 minutes
well I was watching I was watching stuff
and I'm not you know yeah that's how
this video gets taken down by Burger
King yeah
dogs you know he's wearing the the crown
because he wants to take down the Throne
of the liver king sorry I'm bringing it
back we had him we had a 15 minutes talk
about how liver King is done
yeah before we even started oh that was
too funny uh
Among Us uh God damn it would you beat
chainsaw man though probably it's fun a
mogas uh no I've given I was joking
well yeah well we're uh we're pretty
cheap as a person would probably just
take anything that's free and put it in
our thing
that's right
free buy the DVD do whatever let's see
ooh what does that say would you rather
get a quick or a devil fruit and I need
a good reason hmm you know what devil of
fruit I don't know what our system of
One Piece if you eat a devil fruit you
become powerful you get some Powers
the drawback is you can't swim
and you drown like you'll ever become
dead weight as soon as you hit water
yeah
that's literally the weakness and their
main game is their Pirates so I was like
that's awesome okay
that would actually counts
let's see would you what would kind of
power devil fruit power like of the
characters like I know one piece a
little bit Alan knows one piece a little
bit is there a superpower that you would
want
Al
I kind of like Ace
just because really okay I just I just
like fire okay
I burned down a couple of houses along
the way no no don't quote me on that
it's a joke it's a joke don't hit me
how about on that one
uh me
I don't know I'm a big white beard fan I
want that I want those Shockwave Powers
that'd be pretty sweet
uh the Shockwave earthquake Powers I
think yeah pretty much yeah I love it
it's pretty safe that's fantastic oh
that's great
what
no I think they're just saying Among Us
a lot oh we're cutting okay we're gonna
cut that [ __ ] out soon
cut cut it I don't know how it I can't
remember it's too old it's such an old
uh TV show cut it out or something I
can't remember it's so how are we
talking about uh have you never seen uh
Disney sitcom
boy next door or something is that boy
next door is it no it's not boy next
door that's old
uh another one I can't remember it was
remade into a Netflix and it was really
bad
I was always more of a Cartoon Network
kind of kid
okay what was your favorite cartoon
network then uh
Johnny Bravo uh yeah I'm right jack
into Johnny Bravo
oh I love Johnny
no Johnny Bravo Samurai Jack dude
like the music the futuristic music and
[ __ ] that was good stuff
yeah
uh I what's a kids show that I like
Dexter's Laboratory I just really like I
just really like the episode the episode
where he goes I'm a minute to fromage
yeah
he's trying to learn
yes thank you oh that's awesome thank
you okay
I got you ow so back to Summertime
running you were saying that you read
the Manga right
yeah yeah I didn't finish it but so
as much as first or as that season I
think right I haven't seen the manga
I've only done the anime obviously but
uh is it actually like pretty close or
is there any differences is it more gory
I think I think it's pretty close the
model I think similarly gory I haven't
reread it through the moment anime the
anime came out I should it's finished
100 it's finished I think I think it's
finished last time I've seen it but yeah
uh it's out you can people can read it
it's good it's good [ __ ] uh but it's as
gory as uh
the Sci-Fi is as sci-fi as [ __ ] uh
courage County dog is best edit and
Eddie yeah of course how your dog is
best I love oh that was great that show
is scary every time there's a 3D
thing it sucks yeah that's true that's
true
how to beat
um not Muriel uh use this
use this yes bro you can use this oh
that was do you remember the you watched
Courage the Cowardly Dog right or known
did you guys not watch that yeah
actually no actually uh sorry uh courage
I think was technically my favorite
because I'd always call my mom when it
came on now I forgot about it but yeah I
was really into courage and like where's
that that one episode with the The Mummy
guy and he's like the cause oh yeah my
[ __ ] scene freaked me the [ __ ] out
bro remember the one there was like the
cat either was like wearing a suit or
something and he oh he was so spooky
yeah I remember the one with the the
computer he was like doing something
with the computer and the computer was
like haunted or something I can't
remember it's so wild a long time ago
nothing
I got nothing who would win the fight
Kevin from Home Alone or that one
monster from stranger things oh we
should do a how to beat stranger things
that would be fun
that's not our job that's how to be his
job
that's true
be wearing the slab yes if you're in the
chat you've got a perish money okay I
should work on your [ __ ] my guy
foreign
[Laughter]
think so
uh someone's summons has done it that's
probably a guy uh hello guys how are you
oh [ __ ]
they're coming to get me there's a
there's a dot in my forehead
hello guys are you we're good yeah uh
oh no uh what's his face ask about how
he became famous so quickly all right
earlier yeah yeah yep
do you wanna do you want to talk I did
it last time
um all right so basically you know we
all kind of knew each other
and the voice for how to beat we all
knew him kind of but we didn't know each
other I mean we knew each other but not
really kind of like peripherally but we
all knew him and he knew us he was like
hey you guys you should you know start
this channel we're all like yeah he's
like no you really should do this and so
we did and then the first few videos we
put out was like King's game
um yo island of giant insects they it
just they just it just blew up it was
insane like before that all that started
I was doing a bunch of voice over stuff
Dom was doing like modeling writering
writer gig stuff and Al's doing you know
film school and doing other things and
that it just blew up and we're all like
well I think this is a good hint as any
to uh keep doing it
so that's kind of a real quick recap as
you can tell Mr suit guy is a model so
in Thailand so that doesn't count
doesn't really count it's not uh it's
not a New York so who cares any models
watching don't don't come at me Talon's
great
please go at him it's pretty fun please
do oh that'd be amazing
six they stay in oh six six six
oh [ __ ] I remember that episode in
unicorn damn coming in with the facts
nice
Cats won't tell yeah
what okay hello guys oh we're talking
we're talking about Courage the Cowardly
Dog well she was uh bringing the fact
okay yeah and you know and honestly they
should bring back of course Curry dogs
I'll be sick honestly that'll be sick
such a good and that was the biggest
mistake such a good animated show
oh yeah I want to start wouldn't it be
cool if we could start like why don't
the weebs would like it but because it's
not really anime but like you know how
to beat some like pretty sick animation
I don't know there's a lot of stuff out
there I mean we did Korean anime and
that's kind of uh that was pretty that's
pretty sick yeah that was really good
actually uh hopefully you can do more uh
yeah I want to do
Castlevania honestly
yeah how to beat plus anime success
that's basically what happened
uh we thought we were just gonna do it
for a couple of times it would probably
fizzle out and then
promised Neverland came out and it's got
us and then Kyo came out and then it got
like a couple of
like a million like 500 000 in like all
so quickly yeah
uh I thought it was going to get us like
probably 500 views that's probably
pretty good
yeah that's true you're like yeah that's
fine
oh my gosh
uh but yeah it's like um
would you guys count uh Castlevania
avatar The Last Airbender like anime or
anime adjacent or animation
I think Castlevania is more like anime
anime than Avatar that's more like
you know yeah you can like American ice
anime you know yeah
that's kind of what I think
pretty good conversation starter guys
[Laughter]
too much
a mogas
I am boom
timeout chair time out uh sit out sit
out for 500 seconds 300. oh
he disappeared again what else as a kid
I was so scared I would watch Courage
ghost episodes yep uh starket fans he's
talking foul how's it going buddy thanks
for joining us oh I'm so happy you're
here
oh it's so much fun what else Lads oh
one of those big yappers of yours indeed
sorry that we're carrying the
conversation Dom and just hang out and
look pretty all right
that's your job you pretty boy [ __ ]
oh my gosh sorry
so bad because
you're in a business earlier
um do you prefer the second season or
the first season or a season all the way
no comparison no contest bro I'm all
about the abyss as a non-web weeb and it
made an abyss too there was no Abyss it
was like a little bit even though they
were in the abyss there was not much of
missing you know what I mean they really
I mean they're not scared through the
first like like first four a business
levels really quickly in the first yeah
that's true that is true
and I didn't know that there were more
levels I didn't know if there were more
levels actually or is it only six
because Maiden Abyss I thought the same
way as I really like
that what is it the world the Korean
show oh yeah
I can the the one from a webtoon
Griffin the girl the girl's name is
Rachel
uh whipped what are you talking about
you got to give me more uh the guy lives
under
he's no he lives in the basement and he
wants to go up the tower of God Jesus
Christ there it is
like in in a similar fashion of tower of
God I really wanted to be like they can
go up they can go down as deep as they
can and explore like I said kind of like
Sao right it has an interesting concept
where uh gotta go 100 Floors yeah you
gotta go 100 Floors but every floor is a
different challenge or every four has a
different thing you have to do even
though they didn't really go into it
that much in the yeah which I really
kind of sucks but they could have like
hammered it in a little bit more because
that would be way more fun if they come
up with different challenges as they're
risen but uh but yeah I was like I
really liked uh the idea and I don't I
hope they actually make more uh deeper
levels rather than six and they find
like there's like a seventh and eighth
level where the monster is scary they're
doomed as [ __ ] you know what do you
think
uh My worry is that they're going to
beat a dead horse they're gonna it's
kind of like one piece little yeah it's
like too many episodes too many levels
and you're just like the universe and
the power scale just gets so obscenely
large that
it's I mean I won't lie I probably will
still watch it because it's entertaining
but in terms of actually like being like
scared or like
fearful it I that I'll I'll lose that
and I don't wanna I like the the world
that they've built so far and how
they've kept over all the power scale of
it not yeah stupid crazy you know
so that's kind of like that's that's for
me I would prefer like you know so
there's six levels
maybe Max six more you know don't go
don't go to like you know you know lower
28 or you know all those levels and
stuff floor 100. we're meeting uh your
mom's the hell demon that's basically
what happened
uh what do you think uh Dom you haven't
said anything you already know what I
think that was all about the abyssing
and all that with the six levels and
stuff but then like with the the bond
rude you know movie not much of this
thing good movie you know boundary's a
good villain and then but like there
wasn't much of missing the whole thing
is
so I think um I genuinely thought
there'd be Max 7 uh levels
but by the end of how season two was
it's like
I didn't really realize there'd be more
levels to be honest with you so I'm kind
of excited for what they could pull out
of their hat but at the same time like
you know how much can they really pull
out of that hat at this point you know
they already they went so in depth with
the first season
that like I don't know the second season
was it was good but just
no I feel like they're they're running
out of stuff to work with to be honest
how far along would you think you'll
make it on a question
that's not us our kid you might be
thinking of how to beat because that's
what Sam is trying to imply oh Samsung
right oh oh how to beat made a a guy for
hey Tanish uh suroshi how's it going
oh my God how you doing uh you mean
sweet home uh Sweet Home I wish they
made a anime of it Sweden's such a good
anime too it's such a good webtoon and
movie do I know that do I know that how
to beat also made a video out of it it
has a it's a iconic monster big monster
let's see
um
sweetheart
it's a sweet home only
um
it's a cool concept too it comes it will
all fall over right away
uh I can't do uh Red Light Green Light
I'm super dumb and super fidgety oh yeah
I would last a little bit I befriend
people switch on the charm and all that
but then like
I'd probably trip over something at some
point when Dom plays I think Red Light
Green Light he sees a shiny thing on the
ground it's like oh [ __ ] something shiny
oh [ __ ] that's a shiny watch he'll try
to pick it up no yeah I don't think I
think he would have the willpower to be
able to not do it but if it was a watch
he'd be like
I have to
jump for it
oh my gosh
it's French but it says Swiss made oh my
God
before I started watching the anime in
my channel I watch Avatar and I thought
it was an anime and I used to brag it to
my friend so yeah it's anime for me at
least okay Avatar anime Jason I think
it's super because it has the same
styling as an anime the way they
animated their facial features and the
Styles but they're more Americanized in
the way of their storytelling yeah
because early episodes of avatar even
though they're continuing like it's very
procedural where no episode you can
watch it like Loosely uh every episode
is very loose so you don't really have
to watch the whole season but after
season two or season three it's you have
to watch it through because uh it starts
to become more story driven of I think
absolutely if you get if you've seen
Avatar you've seen Avatar not a fan of
the what was it Cora the The Legend of
the Avatar what Legend cord not a fan of
[ __ ] right it's pretty good
it's not
as good as Avatar but it's not aspect
I like the animation I think I like the
animation fight scene it's so cool their
fight scenes are always uh core eyes so
much better your favorite character is
Opera right vodka shut up
I left Roku Avatar Roku the old guy you
know in the first few episodes Avatar
you know with Aang channels Roku and
then you see him and he like freaking
karate chops uh a hole in the tower and
magma comes out and stuff I'm like yes
I really like uh Avatar was it a kiyoshi
uh okay uh yeah the earthbender girl
wait Kyoshi was she an earthbender yeah
yeah she was a fan right she uses a fan
all right but yeah okay I think so wait
hold up hold up side note uh we're
talking about all this earth water fire
bending what was that Cartoon Network
thing
um Challenge Showdown I'm writing that
down I want to watch that again
that was good shotgun do I know that
okay Showdown [ __ ] Ray Mundo such a
stud
show I'm gonna look that out when it
showed up
oh wait what are the comments saying
Cody it is our pleasure to supply you
and the misses with good anime to watch
if you have any recommendations I'm
writing down stuff
Minecraft stuff how do I how do I
actually
a longer
timeout because I don't know how to do
it guys
you'll just be he'll just be this like
uh streams villain every time we we
scream
he's gonna be your arch nemesis
good
weird good manga to watch which one
which one say it's like it's like The
Godfather it's kind of Godfather it's
like what popular rice isekai isekai is
I I have to explain this every time it's
every time there's a new term of manga
or anime I have to explain it I'm part
of it I just can't remember you said Kai
is where a guy guys or a person dies and
they take their soul or they've been
reborn to the next life like in a
different in a different Universe where
there's probably Knights and magic and
[ __ ] like that
he was he's given like a superpower or
he's given the knowledge he brought his
knowledge from the previous world and it
made him op as [ __ ]
uh okay gotcha gotcha gotcha yeah
usually they're always overpowered
usually but sometimes they do it you
know fun and comedically fun way a lot
of them are usually really bad
and like in a in a too easy like a
really bad kind of show there's always
truck [ __ ]
they always get here yeah truck for some
reason
I don't know why
wasn't there a manga is I thought there
was a manga is that guy where
like the guy actually it was kind of
like a lifestyle meets is that guy a
little bit of action but it was
basically like somehow instead of him
getting hit by the truck he actually
takes the truck itself into the other
world and he actually like becomes like
a food supplier for for the other world
and gives them like food from our world
to theirs I can't remember its name but
it was kind of funny it was more comedic
let's see
how's it going thank you for stopping by
again
we're just talking [ __ ] and I'm wearing
the weeb crown oh you know that is a
thing
for sure
um mob psycho is a really good show also
I haven't seen the newest season uh
could be a motorcycle season one mob
cycle mob psycho
psychotic uh psycho
like your personality
shut up you're really not that psycho
though I don't know right
man more like Patrick downman
uh right but the reason why we show
potency is really good Dom is that they
made their own language in the show they
may usually when people like oh we have
a different Elvish language they just
started like they started speaking in
Japanese Japanese
uh right but they just double it's like
oh we're speaking of the show you God
don't know what you were talking about
you know oh but we have to translate it
because uh you know the audience but
they actually made like a language to it
that's why it's really good yeah yeah
is that mob cycle no that's mushoku
tensei oh mob psycho is about a kid who
who has psychic powers yeah and I think
he trying to figure out how to deal with
having too much psychic powers
by you know interesting write this down
hey my grand you are right that is an
actual Burger King Crown yeah that is
actually brilliant
that's right you know it oh well done
did you get that uh oh yes
when I was in America I tried the Nos
Energy Drink
um it was pretty intense unfortunately
here in mango Town Bangkok we don't have
NOS so I'm settling for some sugar-free
Rockstar right now but energy drink
bodies for the wind baby come on wait
what's in that does that have like um
like fruits fructose corn syrup or
something in that it has all the noisy
things uh but it's all on top so unknown
but yeah so
um
it takes me like 30 minutes to like yeah
I'm slow I'm slow
oh yeah oh that's too funny
um what was it gonna oh I got a story
about energy drinks a little random fun
one so I used to work at Subway fun fact
that was always a good time I worked at
Subway I did I used to work at Subway
you want any pictures show the weebs
I not on this phone on one of my old
phones I have a couple photos so when I
used to work there there was a guy's his
name was William but everyone called him
Mike
I don't know doesn't make sense whatever
so he's like I'm breaking down boxes of
like various uh you know Frito-Lay
Doritos whatever I'm breaking down the
boxes they come in and I'm sorting
everything and he comes in he slams the
door shut he's like
I'm like yeah yeah you okay dude
I'm like
what's wrong
I almost died
okay why and he proceeds to tell me how
he knew he was going to be late to get
to the subway that I worked at right and
so he goes on this route and he's he
said he hit like 80 and he went airborne
and then he tells me yeah and I hadn't
slept at all like I haven't slept for
over 24 hours I've had I had like nine
Monster Energy Drinks like about an hour
ago I'm like nine
you've had nine Monster Energy drinks
how are you not dead
uh I'm I remember um one time we I was
gaming for something way back when I was
a young lad you know way back and then
um it was on a gaming competition or
something so I bought I think eight uh
Emily hasip uh in English it's m150 it's
like a local energy drink it's like the
original Red Bull that's it's not the
original Red Bull that's like you know
Red Bull but it's kind of like a it's a
little brother so I had eight of those
suckers and they taste like syrup you
know the concentrated [ __ ]
so yeah I was a bad boy back then too
the bad way back then dude he hasn't
changed
but yeah he makes God damn it among us
is back no damn it how do I bro
don't get her please yes can I hide
users from this channel no I think you
can or something do it
I is hidden he's hidden
dude
come on hit him
this is like this is like entertaining
right now we're all audiences with
everyone we're like watching Al fight
this guy can anyone see him or is is it
no it keeps disappearing
is it disappearing is it gone for
everyone in the chat
uh looks like my IQ is growing after
watching how to beat anime videos
honestly my IQ is dwindling Magic videos
you stay up so late because you want to
make a good video like y'all don't
understand it takes so much time to make
a video so much time we'll research the
anime we'll get the script written we'll
voice the audio we'll make the video
we'll check it we'll try to tweak it try
and make it as entertaining as possible
for you guys and then somehow I was like
I'll bet like four in the morning my
time and I'm like why are you still
awake he's like I need to make a good
video he's a hard worker y'all y'all
Gotta Give him I look up a Joker's game
could be good uh right write it down
down write it down ready
Joker's game
that's an anime yes
I'm looking it up protest Griff is Among
Us Chris Chris
oh that would be fantastic
that does look good
the first two seasons I haven't seen the
new one
uh he's gone again my reflex thing and I
actually beat this I probably lose every
turn 100
I'll lose the moment someone asked me to
tell them the truth or ask them I was
like yeah sure it's like
I'm an affable person
you're an affable person affable you
know what affable is I'm an affable guy
I have the accent I guess so yeah I used
to work at a gas station and found 50
wintering lottery ticket in the trash
and eight ball something hmm all right
well good for you oh [ __ ] yeah nice you
ever played Lottery
um
I have like maybe two or three times
ever because I've never won nothing but
uh the other day actually come kind of
not related but not so me and my child
we had to go get some groceries and
whatnot and you know they have those um
you know you throw a couple bucks or
like a few like 50 cents or something
and you you have the crane game you go
down and it pulls up a stuffed animal or
something and you never win I actually
won something so my kid I like I
actually was able to give them like I
was like here you go and I was like I
actually want something yeah I was
pretty I was pretty happy
yeah yeah I really enjoy crane games
um I do uh one of these days if we ever
get the chance to travel in Japan as a
team as a group oh we gotta do a crane
game crane Japan is is more skills than
luck
uh really yeah it's so it's like you
have to play it smartly a lot of people
actually made it their thing where they
can buy the they can play the crane game
they sell the figurines that they get
and they just get money out of it
interesting niana Khan you got to try
the sugar-free monster the white one
that's good [ __ ]
good [ __ ] yeah I don't really enjoy the
I don't know why I don't really like
sports drinks that's not sports drinks
what am I thinking about Red Bull what's
a Red Bull called energies and your
drinks energy yeah I'm not really that
into them yeah I think the taste is kind
of weird to me what you think about Five
Hour Energy you've probably done that
right oh yeah I mean it's all right I
mean like I drink like I'd like to drink
a ton of those The Taste is addicting
yeah
but I like to I like to sip my [ __ ] I
have this thing where like whatever I
drink energy drink or coffee
um
I won't I'll like chug you know maybe
like a liter of water before I start
this drink or like my iced coffee so
that way whenever I'm sipping on the
coffee or the energy drink I know I'm
not subconsciously drinking out of
thirst but only out of pure enjoyment
and then the drink lasts even longer
quick tip to you guys out there what's
your opinion on my hero Academia I know
it's probably not something you're gonna
do but and the fandom's kind of trash
but what do you think of the anime
itself I think it's probably kind of
like the same level as
probably lower uh like a like a good
Shonen anime
it's like it's a good yeah uh it's fun
to watch it's not really that deep and
anyway it's like I just like deep anime
I like death note guys I put in like
Yagami as my profile picture
those 14 year olds or heard this like I
just watched death note and I'm kind of
like light
[Laughter]
literally every 14 you all out there bro
uh but yeah it's like it's a fun one
it's not like uh it's the same way where
people like I really enjoy Naruto when I
grew it was growing up I really enjoyed
oh yeah I was growing up it's similar
Vibe as them I think bleach is uh better
written kind of maybe I think so but
that could be bias and Nostalgia on my
side but my hero Academia is really fun
have you seen my hair Academia Griffin
I'm assuming Dom has oh yes I have
absolutely I've heard of it though oh
for sure
yeah there's a Death Note the musical
what what is there's a what in Japan
they made a musical
someone probably recorded it and
translated it
should we just we should watch
that how to read the book and that's not
the musical wow
that's something my goodness we should
just do every spin-off other than the
actual anime
that's right everything
that'd be actually funny wait didn't uh
Tokyo ghoul's done some spin-offs right
or other alternate
uh season two it's basically season
three they just call it weird
something
[Music]
uh
I don't think anyone really wins Mega
Millions of people allow people to win
thousands here and there but someone
just recently won uh talking about that
lottery ticket
I still want to know your opinion on
angels of death if you had watched it no
I haven't seen it I don't watch my
friend drinks two and a half two five
minute energies and four monsters a day
and wonder if he is depressed over time
God damn absolutely well too much
fun facts geez fun fact I put on my
trainer cap on gee like because I used
to do like personal training and
nutrition and crap and those energy
drinks and things they all they do a
number on your hormonal system like it
it messes with your moods and crap for
sure
my gosh what's your favorite anime Griff
or my favorite so far Domino let's just
say so far working with how to beat
anime and which one's your favorite
anime yeah Dom you go first all right
favorite anime I was talking to a friend
about this the other day I was weaving
out off camera that's how much of a
weave King I am basically I would say
because it was one of the most weirdest
things and I thought it was gonna do
[ __ ] but that's got a soft place in my
heart but for like special reasons other
than that I would say
um
in terms of World building and pure joy
I would say made in Abyss I genuinely
want to get the maiden Abyss like layer
poster seven layer six layers and put
that bad boy up on my wall or something
I'll be sick and but in terms of
actually watching the anime and actually
enjoying it and you know not like
looking at my watch or whatever I would
say
um honestly I'd say Death Note
like in terms of like actually like
being like Oh okay okay you know like
drinking my energy drink looking at the
screen being like what's light gonna do
now bro
so yeah I would say yeah Geo in terms of
the soft spot if we hit a million Subs
I'm gonna get a Geo tattoo just saying
putting that on air now I don't give a
[ __ ] all right
calm down let's calm down right and then
it made in Abyss in terms of World
building and Death Note in terms of like
an anime I'd sit down and watch
willingly
every millions of Tom will get you get a
new tattoo got a new tattoo and on his
cheek like a prison tattoo of people
fish
oh no the cow the cow I'm from guillot
it's good yeah and then one random cow
and then one random just a lot of fish
and one random cow one [ __ ] cow
oh
uh I've just thought I've just thought
about the energy drink process okay it's
not a crazy thing
what's your favorite anime not so far
but you watch anime out of like our our
stuff but what about you
okay so does it have to be within our
stuff or just whatever whatever
whatever
um so I would say Samurai 7
um
uh berserk
um and then
Oh shoot what was it it's totally like a
like massive power
um
heroic age
is another one I like
oh you're like uh
kind of medieval kind of anime
oh yeah yeah sure do you like timer
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
I love the flamer yeah we could do
Claymore I think we should probably
write it down write it down I'm writing
it down if you ever watched full metal I
just uh I've always read it I've reread
it every time every couple of years I
reread full metal such a good tight
Manga and Anime
Fullmetal Alchemist Brotherhood uh
such a good one
anime
I really like
uh
what do Island
brain fart I don't know I like that
guy's the actual biggest weed there is
bro no but I'm gonna call him like Lasik
when I when I like something it's
usually basic stuff but I read a lot of
stuff
uh kind of like like I like your name uh
if you ever seen it
oh wait quick Side Story one before um
before we I was I was heading back from
La I was gonna have to leave La back to
Bangkok so a couple years ago and bobcat
for some reason he was like damn you
need to watch this anime with me I got
the Blu-ray of some [ __ ] and I was
like bro I gotta pack and [ __ ] and it
kept on bugging me about this stupid
anime and it happened to be uh
um
what the [ __ ] was it called literally
were just talking about it what was it
called Bobcat your name yeah your name
so literally that was actually one of
the first animes I watched yeah and Lily
that
and it was like three and a half hours
it was a whole thing I had to go to the
bathroom like four times really long but
really good story oh there you go yeah
yeah it's pretty good see that I [ __ ]
love this anime it's like it's not even
it's sad though that was a good joke no
it's no it's good it's not sad oh good I
thought it was a sad one well you think
you think it's kind of sad I don't want
to spoil it you think it's kind of sad
in the beginning because like the
yeah I'll just stop talking but it's
pretty good it's good it's good
I can share anymore
how's it going guys thank you for
stopping by
it the boy of friend when he was
transformed into the fishbot thing
tatted on you oh God please though
please no I know exactly what you're
talking about
everybody dude
best thumbnail out of everything that I
made it's my favorite sexy I want
something sexy Hulk with a dildo in his
mouth sexy as [ __ ] bro
he's laughing but he's really not
excited about that idea
oh this is a question for you Bobcat
like your name you're timing I'm timing
you out
no what I liked it I'm chilling no no
star kid Phil said he didn't like your
name
oh [ __ ]
no it's fine I enjoyed it it's a it's a
fun movie
uncultured uncultured that's fine it's
fine I think I think it's
I think it's weird that it I think
it grabbed me in a way that's like the
music is just really fun I watched it uh
I think I was traveling to Japan at the
time because I was meeting family I
always haven't seen them for a while
so uh a lot of my family were traveling
to Japan I was like
what was that Indonesian spirit
Indonesia
uh no uh something fell but yeah I don't
know
um but yeah uh I was trying with Japan
to meet my family and then people were
watching it it's like what because I was
in LA it's gonna take a couple hours
uh
so people are watching it and I wanted
to watch what they're watching and then
I I've seen it I finally found it and I
watched it I just [ __ ] cried bawled
my [ __ ] eyes out in the middle of the
seat and everyone I looked around and if
some people were also crying
and I watched it because and then I
tried to watch something else and I kept
re-watching it again because I liked it
and I cried again more so sure goodness
you
oh boy awesome that's good that's how we
bonded uh that's true that's right
that's one of those things
um Bobcat shivangi asked a really good
question for you about uh is Anime
better than manga like many people
suggest uh to read the Manga over the
anime uh it depends Attack on Titan yeah
100 anime is way better uh
really yeah anime is way better if
you've seen Attack on Titan if the manga
bro [ __ ] [ __ ] art is it really it's
not the same or like it's not great uh
interesting but one punch Man manga is
number one
okay yeah oh yeah I think our video is
number one and then Mongoose number two
okay usually I would say manga is better
than the anime because it's also time
gets ranting because like with manga
yeah true
like there's just in a way more time I
know it's really hard to make manga
especially over in Japan you know that
whole process but
it's like in like a book you know like
Lord of the Rings you know great movies
but there's still information things
that they either changed or they
couldn't put in from the book so it's
just you know I mean it's it's hard but
I I think that um yeah I agree with what
Al said you know if it's Attack on Titan
anime manga
and also if you ever want to see Rita
good uh a manga or a good book forget
this book called a look back that is
[ __ ] adorable what is it okay bring
that in closer yeah hold up hold up what
is that
it's from the creator of uh chainsaw man
same artist okay look back geez all
right okay uh it's about kids who wanted
to be mangocas a manga artist and then
and then stuff happens in the middle and
it's really good people should read it
it's good [ __ ] it does seem interesting
we should do a how to beat on that no
it's just super super scary it's just uh
it's not that intense no but like make
it intense like as possible it's like oh
I have to write a new character what am
I going to do
was there any way for REM to live in
Death Note uh I think yes he's told
the name of Val to light and then she
would suffer
she should be told the name L of the
name of Elton light and then she would
suffer a Punisher of her what
wait is REM the other shiniga the other
shinigami's name yeah yeah right
um
I don't really know the rules of the
whole Shinigami regardless basically if
you try to interfere with someone who is
supposed to die
all right
the Asian Spirits are traveling
[Laughter]
my book's phone and it just dropped on
everything that's why I'm going
he's gone
that's actually true uh Global Gabby
about the attack on Titan I feel like it
would have been so much better if half
the Titans did not look like actually
drunk people and like because some of
them were pretty scary but then other
ones are just like
their teeth are scary bro
yeah all right Fair there there's some
guy with a big ass teeth scary as hell
yeah
uh I'll try to buy the book yeah you can
buy the book it's good I like the book
uh
it's good it's good writing if you ever
want to watch something that's not
chainsaw man Fire Punch is a really good
atom a really good book they never made
it into an anime but it's a good book
because it's too dark honestly they're
not gonna make an end to the anime Fire
Punch man I wait another thing it's Fire
Punch
fire uh punch isn't there another anime
or Manga that is
one punch man uh no you're thinking of
the firefighting uh the yes no that one
not that one okay fire punch is a
different story oh yeah I'm looking at
the I love reading a right to left and
back to front it's different but kind of
natural
it's it's weirding me out in a way
because I'm so used to reading it that
way and if I try to watch them if I try
to read a Marvel comic book it [ __ ]
freaks me out
foreign
that's why I don't really want to read
Marvel stuff or I kind of
I kind of naturally got into manga just
you know but when I first started
reading I don't have any like books I
would just go to like Barnes and Noble
and just read it there you know but
um I didn't realize you were supposed to
read it a certain way so when I first
started reading I'm like wait this
this would make sense why is the
storyline going it wasn't until like 50
pages later Griff realized oh backwards
like this is so annoying this is some
like French New Wave type of
do you think Levi Ackerman is over hype
what do you think
you've seen Levi Dom he's cool as [ __ ]
he's probably he's like
he's like uh he's like yeah yeah I think
initially I I named him uh Captain stud
face or something yeah I told you he was
like no this guy is [ __ ] sick what
are you doing yeah I named Levi like
yeah something and then these guys were
like no you better keep his [ __ ] name
because they're gonna come after you and
I was like all right all right
but yeah he was cool I mean I don't know
over hyped uh
I mean he did some cool [ __ ] he did some
you know
some cool [ __ ]
yeah I'd like them I thought he was
pretty good yeah what do you think about
fruit baskets versus the original one oh
hey remember album we were over in LA
and we were uh yeah you know uh one of
the girls like uh a few baskets because
I ever want to see us wait watch uh when
we did the Anime Expo the one that you
were never able to come because you're
all right you're a piece of [ __ ] yeah
um presence is prison School
no could be cool
uh he knew I know exactly what that is
what about Frozen school fill on the
Weeping High School of death and prison
minus zombies
basically uh fan service there's no it's
a lot of answers but the basic story is
there's a all-girl school they want us
to be co-ed right so they brought in a
couple of guys but this school has a
weird system if you do something bad
you're put in a prison so these five
guys did something kind of
etchy and they were putting in the kind
of was like ah it's kind of cringe but
they were put into the system and they
were put into prison and they made it
them into like they have to do weird
stuff to these girls and it's like it's
so weird it's such a weird show for them
trying to gain independence or freedom
because they're in like they're in an
island or they're in like a dormitory
it's a weird way of it's so weird that I
got out of the manga I was like I don't
really enjoy this wait this is uh an
anime or it's an anime it's in it's a
manga too
we could try how to beating it sounds
fun
yeah because you'll enjoy watching it I
learned I've never seen this I've never
heard of it it sounds interesting sounds
really good watched a couple of episodes
I'll check it out I've watched death
parade Al have you watched death parade
I've watched death parade I haven't seen
death for it I need to read I need to
watch a lot more stuff than you do I
don't
huh what no way do I I don't watch more
stuff than you do no I probably watch a
lot more stuff than I do because I don't
really watch a lot of anime yeah you
watch a lot more anime than a script I
watch a lot more I read a lot more manga
than probably you do
but I don't really watch that anime
some people online attack me saying you
like any
other Warrior than Levi and aot you are
weird that's why
this thought grew on me I think it's
fine liking anything else is fine you
don't have to be you'd have to like the
same things people like but Levi's cool
Levi's cool as [ __ ] but you don't have
to like it Aaron's kind of wasn't a big
fan of his uh haircut but other than
that yeah
have you guys have you seen our video on
how to go with the dead yeah
Griffin didn't enjoy the experience no
see here's the thing right initially I
think it was before high school the Dead
no he we talked about doing High School
the dead Griffin was like nah nah nah
and then I think I said do it
yeah but I think I think um didn't we do
what we did with um devil man cry baby
that was another anime that Griff did
not want to do but what happened was I
wrote the whole script and I sent it to
Griff we didn't tell him what we were
doing next and then basically he was
kind of forced to do it at the last
minute I don't know we're not gonna have
another video if you don't do it or if
you did devil man cry baby and then
after that he was like all right if I've
done devil man I can do high school I
can't remember exactly what happened I
think
um well shoot what was it I think it was
I don't know why I feel like it might
have
done
and I was really into my zombies too so
I was really like being pissed off that
Griff didn't want to do high school
because I I you know I love zombies
sniper guy I don't like the sniper guy
what what I don't want to be the sniper
guy dude you're kind of like the sniper
yes and I have the haircut shut up
you got the haircut and the glasses
glasses guy
ah it's already there yeah I'm gonna
watch this after this live do it it's
good you're gonna like it it's good [ __ ]
it's like actually fun [ __ ] uh have any
watched it uh they're gonna watch it if
you read any dark
topic manga
like recently or ever and my questions
it's a dark topic oh yeah super dark
uh that's another Dark One
uh hey nice
zombie hey there you go you got a zombie
fan good for you if you have any other
zombie animes guys or shivangi uh let me
know because I literally make these guys
do it
no I'll do it he really does like those
yeah that was the other one we did
um
Soul station
yeah yeah
it's good yeah good [ __ ]
uh didn't you say they were
amazing season two that's right yeah
uh sure my favorite my kind of currently
that I really like kind of dark it's
called blood on tracks it's a good manga
blood on tracks
it's like a psychologically
psychological drama but a very weird mom
who's super too into his her son oh
sounds fun oh it's like overprotective I
know a creepy way it's overprotective in
a creepy way uh Tracy always has an M
zombie episode It's like a
like an episodic procedural right if I
remember correctly interesting it's
writing it down
yeah wait in the last last live stream
we did they someone mentioned are we
gonna do Tracy remember it's like the
the Thailand uh
a Thai anime thing right
isn't it Thailand yeah it's uh
Philippines yeah Philippines yeah
oh okay yeah devil man crab is so good
that ending was mind-blowing that ending
is sad they all died yeah that ending
was actually really [ __ ] sad like God
damn it's like how wait really I mean
how every kid who tried to write a story
and then they all died in the end
and you're like yeah
true legendary berserk was good yes it
is good berserk's still continuing it's
weird I I'm I have mixed feelings about
it the chapters still going someone else
is drawing it now
I have mixed feelings about it
I'm not sure about that the only people
who knew that who knows the story is the
editor and a couple of other assistants
that worked for the berserk artist
oh
one of my friends suggested me to read
dead two that I might that is not that
bad it's a bit kinda
a gory in a sense of that's all right
they're trying too hard
uh Dead Two uh if you guys if you never
heard of it Griff or Dom probably never
heard of it I haven't uh it's about
a couple of high school kids who wanted
to be like YouTube famous and then they
found this
Channel called dead tube where people do
this black
uh like dark web kind of [ __ ] where you
kill people and then you get likes and
you get views and get money
and the way they do it they do crazier
and crazier [ __ ] as things goes along I
don't know if they're ever gonna do an
anime of it because it's a bit too
dark
for them to do it they could be though
okay yeah well they have to cut out a
lot of the story or things like kind of
odd Story
the same way as they cut a lot of the
[ __ ] stuff and redo of the Healer
now that one is a very hard that's like
that's hard pass other if we were able
to cut stuff out of it we can do it
hopefully I think we can do it what's it
called redo the Gila redo it yeah it's
basically like hentai that's basically
what it is it's full-on hentai but they
really just uh whenever there's a hentai
scene you just see a fireplace
what it's so dumb bro
that's
nah I like I thought like oh I like
maybe the first episode which I was like
oh look this looks kind of interesting
and then it gets like super just like
whoa if we ever if we ever do it we'll
surprise you at the last minute oh okay
got it right no I haven't a i generated
of Griff voice
[Laughter]
wait uh niana Khan said have you have
you seen um Lupine the third castle of
castillago uh I haven't seen any Lupine
movies so I can't say stuff uh Lupine
but they don't know nothing made a good
they recently made a good Lupine anime
uh anime movie I don't know if it's any
good oh gosh it's not the anime kind of
shock is lucid a criminal or like a
detective uh it's like a criminal
okay it's like uh they're trying to
steal stuff remember correctly how to be
finished right uh that's not a I don't
think that fits with our theme guys Soul
station is uh yeah it's like the prequel
to a trainer Busan like how the virus
like paw it's it's basically it's like
it's a same world different story kind
of thing yeah
she's a zombie anime zombie showing the
bright side of it apocalypse give it a
try they sound pretty fun all right I'll
uh how disappointed isn't the first few
seasons pretty good seven deadly sins
and then that's that specific season
season three or season four they gave it
to a [ __ ] studio and then it was so [ __ ]
it was so bad I actually uh I've seen uh
Lupine so long got
yeah so long ago
yeah
damn
for seven deadly sins was it the bad
Studio when that was in charge of it
when they were doing the one verse it
was it pride versus Leonidas or
something it's Pride versus Leonidas
that episode specifically was really bad
and I think either they trusted the
wrong Studios because the studio is
pretty new
because I don't know it's like it's
weird they have a weird deal with a
different studio and then they [ __ ] up
something right
but yeah I wonder what that phone call
must have been like uh so that's what
happened
they made a sequel to seven deadly sins
uh mango eyes
really of course Four Horsemen of the
Apocalypse or something
they're keeping on track with the
the theme you know
would we ever do like a how to beat
manga you know I mean that I mean I know
but it already sounds like a lot of
thinking I'm thinking it's a lot of
editing bro it's like if you know how
hard it is to to make a shot of a panel
interesting
uh that'd be so much fun though uh but
you know I'm excited for junji Ito
jujito manga is probably good record of
Ragnarok was also it's also a good one
uh we had that written down somewhere
records of Ragnarok
yeah last time yeah yeah Al's asked me
to look at the junior what was it the
shorts a bunch of those short stories I
haven't done that yet I'm sorry I gotta
do that it's all right
uh world that would be good we need we
need more people working with us
uh put it into the comments that's right
you want to submit your application
how many applications we get
hello how to be team what's up suhan
YouTube man
how's it going guys preaching how to
beat uh as the God's will manga oh
that'd be so good it sucks if they made
a movie they made a [ __ ] movie first
and a live-action movie and not an anime
didn't how did they do that yeah he did
one yeah it's their best anime I think
it's their best uh it's one of their
biggest
but it was the biggest one
which one uh as the God's will if you
ever seen their channel it's the one
with the DaRuMa the red the red thing on
the table
um
okay yeah
uh sure
did y'all saw the ending with of
higarashi series what's your thought we
haven't done we should actually start
hikarashi part two
oh yeah we haven't done that in a while
yeah no no we haven't we do all right
someone earlier schedule
oh we do have a question for you guys
who's here what do you guys uh which
JoJo should we do all right guys ah
there you go
um how's it going let me put it as
give me a second a thing yeah put a
thing like a pole you know or see if we
can get people to do that that'd be cool
I need to go to a little down
you gotta go to the Little Dom's room no
it's probably a tiny tiny room because
Tom's not here so I'm not gonna make fun
of him all right oh that's right
classroom of the elite uh
yeah we might do that one I think it
could be it could be a fun one is that
right on the list that might be already
on the list I don't remember
foreign
very complicated
hagarashi has a lot of anime
it's too complicated
no it's it'll be fine
it'd be all right
I'm gonna what did that say
have we seen Banana Splits nope I have
not seen but not a splits I'm talking
about are we talking about sugar left
nope not talking about sugar life
do
[Music]
oh [ __ ] I [ __ ] up all right that's
messed up
wow oh no and the pole I messed up where
are we doing it that's not too late it
just didn't happen
oh that's too funny vamp
there you go we'll get it fixed
so do you have any questions for us
please feel free
I'd love to answer some questions
tendency if you have any voiceover
questions I would be more than happy to
answer some questions about that too uh
that's always fun I can give also give
voice over questions if you guys want
that
uh because you know my I always give up
good good advice for people apparently
that's right uh just get good guys
that's basically it hey
hey you rocks a rocks I don't know how
to pronounce your name but Baraka won
against Canada okay cool
I'm sorry I can't I can't add more I can
only add four that's [ __ ] uh the
first four I guess uh do I have any pets
I used to I used to uh all right Jojo I
know that there's part five and part six
and we'll do it later
if you guys have any suggestions of
which JoJo we should do I just learned
of junji Ito I want to start reading him
it's so good Gigi so it's really good
you should do it uh the poll ended so
soon I didn't even vote uh
do you have any pets I do have pets uh
let me take let me show you photos
he's got some cute little doggies
what about little dogs
do you have any pets that's one of the
questions you have any pets
uh
no no pets nope
did you have a cat down what the [ __ ]
well we know family yeah family's got a
we got a little cat
but yeah me no no
okay
there they are
look at them look at that cute
cute son of [ __ ] they're named uh
Wasabi and sashimi nope
and Tom used to do this thing every time
he saw a picture of the dog he was like
oh I need 13 a mantra and get that
little poop and I need to get some
Chopsticks
it's 100 truth you all don't understand
he was like crazy whenever I call him
and then I show him the photos
I need you to do me a favor I need you
to grab a couple of Chopsticks and put a
put in there like what the [ __ ] are you
talking about what the [ __ ] they're
saying I just like cute things come on
my criminal what hello man hey look at
that Global Gabby says okay those are
cute I will admit
all right those are cute
as [ __ ] all right
adorable paparinos uh young Joseph is
hilarious but with the way he talks and
his poses are cute
uh who would die first in a zombie I'll
probably die first uh
now honestly I'll die last right before
they announce they have a cure
[Laughter]
guys I'm really also very clumsy in real
life oh
you know this uh Dom it became a running
joke in school it's [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah I don't know how it happened
but uh
but yeah it's uh but yeah it's funny
I'll probably die last and then
and then uh and then they found a cure
and it was like [ __ ]
is good I I think like the first we had
sympathy with the humans and then the
with the shikis true yeah
um for sure I wish that video didn't do
shite all right it did all right it did
okay it did okay it did okay
was my baby bro the first one I put in
work
I mean oh I like what he did there anime
yeah I remember that you know
and before
um we started doing like these live
streaming q and A's which is so much fun
we have like a bunch of these old
podcast recordings that we got just
stored somewhere we actually did a whole
bet they were thinking we're going to
upload we talked about the cheeky anime
and whatnot maybe we'll actually do one
for real with you guys too that would be
fun but like
I remember talking about like it would
just be a problem like
if for just regular shakies to actually
exist unless you were a gene Roe like
the hybrid species that could survive
with minimal or pretty much no human
blood like
they really you should you shouldn't let
them stay around because they'll just
expand you know they'll take over the
town that they're in if anyone haven't
seen the cheeky the anime it's basically
these vampires that try to take over
this town and eventually you know make
that like their Hub their their home and
so I was like uh problem what happens
when there's no no more humans they're
just going to keep spreading so like
because there was a question we had
written up was like could she key and
humans actually coexist and I was like
well unless you're a gene raw hybrid no
you know what I mean so that's what I
think she is about vampires guys in case
I said that I said oh you said it okay
I can't remember you just want to use
one full hands I was okay I did go full
him on that one yeah
uh if y'all ever hire more help I would
love to be a writer I love to read
novels and one goal one day we'll hire
writers uh one day hopefully soon
honestly kind of soon
hopefully
we always say if we if we do um yeah
we'll definitely uh you have corgis I
want one so bad that Corgi was given to
me by a friend so that's why I was like
I I got the Shiva and then a friend of
mine's like do you want a corgi he's
like yeah kind of it's like all right
so I got two at similar times that boy
Akira was just young blood idiot
teenager and the anime teaches how
superpowers should go in the teenager's
hands
true true true
I think Bell tendency wasn't in the
anime I think I panel tendency was a was
a manga issue that could be it
uh I think we're probably I think people
are rooting for first part so we'll
probably do first part
oh really okay
um all right let's see we'll see right a
novel
that's writing out some important notes
my favorite JoJo is uh
foreign
I can't remember his name
the JoJo that's gone the Italian I've
only ever seen the first one I've only
ever seen the first one you should watch
it
I've read it
um
I stopped in I think season six and part
six
mostly because the translation got wonky
so I was like I can't read this anymore
right
there was a video of a video of what no
no no you go ahead you go Burger Shot
how's it going meet your Burger King
laughs
if y'all could bring a Pokemon IRL what
would it be
what's the [ __ ] hours forget the
squirter guy the turtle Squirtle
Squirtle scanners the cannon Square well
you guys the Cannons
Blastoise that's yeah I don't know who's
a squirter Squirtle Squirtle Squirtle is
the like the biggest stage oh he's a
little cute one and then the the biggest
Squirtle is the the tank Turtle yeah
that's plaster yeah ah the tank Turtle
if we did how do we Pokemon that's gonna
be one of the name of them Peg Turtle
uh you know that in French Blastoise is
what is it the Tonk that's it I've heard
someone say this actually uh
start get felt that's weird suggestions
[Music]
okay
any horror suggestions horror and
zombies are my fave ones
uh
if you if it's manga you should watch
junji Ito there's also a drifting
classroom which is also very horror
there's one not to be confused with
Tokyo Drift there's any confusion
no okay are you confused
it just bounce that out there I'm like
what oh hey Bobcat not you about got the
other Bobcat it's Bobcat Jr
nope it's back to Bobcat God damn it one
of my one of the most badass scenes in
anime is a gin when the old guy is going
to save the MC and he's cutting off his
arm with the kids yes oh my God what's
the what the hell's his name or what did
I put his name as
that's true
what are we gonna say no oh I was just
gonna say remember the bit where they
had to keep constantly shooting Saito
and you know we're literally talking the
video it's like
um yeah literally bro what was that good
idea but maybe you could have done that
a little bit better yeah just try to I
don't know why they didn't
bring the car closer to
the car
carsato what the [ __ ] it's open
right
Phantom blood is the first part with
Jonathan joestar and Dio
do
where are we at on that pole where is it
oh it's done okay
I don't know we stopped it have you guys
read Sakamoto days it's funny talking
about this good [ __ ] it's good anime too
it's like I know nothing about that one
you have to give me that
uh I don't know how to explain it but
I'll look it up okay we'll do that one
oh no it's not I'm thinking of different
Sakamoto then it's on this guy
uh Sakamoto days is basically a guy who
retired
uh assassin retired
gone with the family has a child and
then gained a lot of weight it becomes a
chubby guy and then people start to
figure out that he's like a legendary
assassin Hitman so they try to kill him
and like you know John Wick kind of way
but he always talks in like a comedic
it's called Sakamoto days it's a good
mom it does sound good yeah it's fun
it's a fun comedic mama
uh young Joseph is best but I like Cujo
I haven't made it I haven't made it last
diamond is unbreakable though
Jolene is really good uh part six the
one where she's in prison have you guys
watched the anime movie Lupine Lupine I
haven't seen it yet
favorite moment and Attack on Titan ah
favorite moment
well the most recent season's pretty
sweet is it the most reason where like
you have the whole ships they're on like
the ocean they have that big Armada and
they're firing these Cannon rounds into
the ocean trying to stop this wave of
Titans swimming in the water and you
know the Titans can give off like crazy
hot steam it can like basically vaporize
you right yeah and there's a part where
they're coming towards the ships and
they go underneath them but the steam
that they're giving off vaporizes
everyone on the boat and you see it I'm
like whoa
yeah that's like oh it's pretty intense
it's intense I don't need to watch the
final season of
Attack on Titan I haven't seen it yet
is it over and is it over over is it
still going
uh y'all let me know I don't remember if
it's done done I think it's almost done
with Attack on Titan shivangi okay so a
sun story people get sleep paralysis in
real life but I saw a dream of me having
sleep process while I was sitting in a
dark room I thought it was going to die
in my dream
there you go
yeah when I was a kid I used to get
really scared of like demons attacking
me so but then I'd always get sleep
paralysis so I put the Cozy over me but
I left a hole for my mouth to breathe so
in case I get paralyzed I can still like
breathe and [ __ ] oh you would get sleep
paralysis all the time bro [ __ ] weird
yeah my wife she's she used to get it
like she used to get uh sleep paralysis
sometimes and like oh yeah she just said
like like used to mess with her head bad
sometimes honest
a little bit yeah
uh I just can't have blankets over my
mouth when I have sleep paralysis no
that's why that's why I let the hole so
it's like yeah so if I get paralyzed you
know oh okay yeah
maybe in a slightly inappropriate
question when when could your family
would you have siblings right yes
no I'm talking like Dom did he assembly
uh yeah yeah okay did they ever like see
that you have sleep paralysis and they
just decide to like mess with you or
something you couldn't like move or
something uh no no they don't know if
you're yeah you know because I always
cover my entire body for some reason I
was really scared of demons getting me
of some [ __ ] so I'd always cover
myself completely and then I'd leave a
little hole so even if I didn't have
sleep paralysis I'd still be in the same
I still look the same kind of so no they
thank [ __ ] god dude new fear unlocked
I was just scary well like my wife
people should be like you know his her
sleep paralysis like she would be able
to like maybe like twitch like her
finger or or a foot or something but
like you said no one's really gonna look
for that but she's like yeah move wake
me up and yeah do you just move them do
you just like like try to shake them or
do you know it's like you have like one
party a body or something that maybe you
can move and then if you can try and
move it like you know that one part then
it kind of like unlocks your whole body
yeah something
something like that yeah so I always try
to move my legs or something when I have
that yeah
yeah
no usually like when churn and I first
started dating I like you know we'd be
cuddling up and she'd fall asleep she
would tell me if I'm like starting to
Twitch my foot or something means I I
can't actually like move myself so I
kind of like over time I like developed
this thing if I was next to her I could
tell that you know she'd be wiggling I
would just kind of shake her and she
would
you know come out of it she doesn't have
that anymore but it was like it was
freak I tell you what
because it's like your uh your brain is
kind of still in the REM kind of stage
so anything you say anything you think
yeah shows up that's why like you're
afraid when you say you're afraid of
demons when you have to think when you
think it's like demons don't count
demons come [ __ ] demons shows up yeah
foreign
let's see are y'all gonna play doing how
to beat the big three Luffy Naruto
Ichigo ah well actually earlier we did
ask you guys if there was a Arc
specifically within one piece that you'd
like us to do because as we all know
loot you know one piece is super long so
give us a suggestion on which uh story
arc we should try to do okay which Arc
all right
[Music]
yeah but no yeah I never finished most
games but like I still liked it that's
good [ __ ] so how many games do you have
oh yeah it's true but it was a good game
I still appreciate it but yeah
oh yeah neonicon seven great [ __ ]
movie
it's in the box
oh Marine Ford legendary okay
we got one from Marine Ford Shadow dies
twice it's good
uh same as
what is the other one Elden ring
uh
you mean God of War Ragnarok it's game
it's games
okay gotcha yeah God of War
boy I'm still playing the second one the
the sequel so no spoilers I love that
guy's voice you know because it's just
so like
Olympus cannot contain me it's so I love
that voice I was a big fan of the PSP
PSP game it's good [ __ ] that's
yeah yeah
if you all haven't seen the last podcast
go watch that one we had a whole Spiel
where we talked about how much dominant
I don't really like that time where
Kratos met with Aphrodite
you remember the scene God damn it's the
only scene oh okay
unknown what time is it there well
I live over in the U.S they dumps
Thailand we got Al over in Indonesia so
uh it's currently midnight I know okay
yeah it's I mean it's getting closer
like quarter past midnight and then no
time that's right where are you at on
your caffeinated beverages my good
self-proclaimed weeb King uh okay well
good thing you asked so I finished um I
finished the protein milk I finished uh
the two Rock Star Energy drinks and then
I finished this green tea sugar-free
thing
um so now all I've got left is this um
Pepsi no sugar thing
pretty much it oh Tyler doesn't know how
much my 7-Eleven ran out of another
energy drink though oh no okay 10 45 10
45. is there is there a location where
there's like a 30 minute
time difference that's crazy well
there's a few issues
is there like a place that's like
usually it's like per hour not per 30
minutes
right yeah but I think there's a few
there's a few time zones
um where it's like
that kind of all right but most I think
it's like oh okay I'm sure I was like I
never seen it but probably oh give me a
thing probably they're probably right
have we ever heard of the grave of
fireflies oh you ever seen uh no it's a
it's a Ghibli movie about uh
after World War II
oh it's a super sad movie that wasn't
really produced by Ghibli so it's not in
their catalog but it's created by Ghibli
in a way okay it's very good uh wait
which ones Studio Ghibli which one grave
of the fireflies
is that uh something I'd like is it like
a how to beat thing or I'm not sure if
we could even no no it's not what's it
great fireflies uh crave off the
fireflies yeah it's good [ __ ] it's good
travel hey 11 37 Texas India very nice
hey girl you know there's a
I really wanted to go to Texas I hear uh
they have good food
that's right they have some anime expos
in Texas and is well as India uh if the
sponsors if the sponsors if the Expo
conventions wants to bring us and get us
tickets we'll probably be interested
that's very true
literally bring this to the Expo
oh my gosh that would be so funny I
never lose it never lose it yeah it's
gonna become a thing everyone's like
where's the crowd
honestly it'll be fun yeah I even get
like a scepter and [ __ ] like we'll make
it official bro
oh dear
tune in exam is perfect for how to beat
it is that's true
the tune in exam have you ever seen
Naruto Griffin oh yeah
remember the tune in next the exam part
of it all
there's a test and then like there's a
written test and then there's a and then
the one and the I think the one in the
forest I think yes that would be the
better one for sure yeah and then you
get the snake guy what is his name uh he
showed up and actually yes
Naruto but I stopped reading it through
boruto it's kind of slow I borrowed two
I couldn't really get into I'm like I
think they're trying to World build
currently so it's kind of slow and it's
also a different pacing
Tom lives in Thailand bro probably stays
there uh stays getting better it's all
right
foreign
[Laughter]
North Carolina sweet uh
portamang is good I'll read it I'll try
to read it again
uh you know about mirukochan uh oh
America
is that the
is that the story where there's a girl
who's able to see ghosts but she tries
to ignore them
looking this up maruko Chan
yeah yeah she can see dead people she
just chooses to ignore them that could
be kind of funny as [ __ ] it's like it's
comedic because every time the ghosts
scared the living [ __ ] out of her but
she just lets it be since she just walks
out
but I don't know if it fits we can try
but I don't know I don't know it's one
of those things where we have to figure
it out that'd be more like April Fool's
kind of thing you know
me which one which one
uh it's called mierukochan it's a it
could be something it's on Netflix you
can watch it though to see all right
writing it down okay
uh I'm on the border between West
Virginia and Virginia is VA Virginia
where's Virginia yeah I literally just
finished uh watching a Hannibal the TV
show and all that [ __ ] goes down in
Virginia I'm like God damn scary but
I've been there I've been there once
it's really pretty really pretty oh yes
me and the wife on one of our travels we
uh we were down in Virginia area near
West Virginia whatever they had they got
so many ticks over there it is insane I
think they have the most amount of
different kinds of ticks in in West
Virginia it is they have a lot of like
oh yes
scary one oh yeah oh yeah that's a scary
one
um we went hiking it was gorgeous
beautiful we could see like five
different counties or whatever it was
like five different things
no on our feet we looked down we had
like between the two of us we probably
had 30. on you like just on our actually
been not bite you down no no no no we
had like long socks and crab and all
this stuff but I was like oh my gosh
I get so freaked out when people say
there are ticks around I get so freaked
out over it uh because I don't know I
can handle a mosquito or even like a
leech but ticks are super scary I don't
know why
very small yeah
it was awesome that's true I'm looking
at my my sneak and I'm watching go like
I think uh
um and how to beat
[Music]
um
uh Terror terraformers video or whatever
they talked about using the power of one
of the ticks or something and they're
like the fastest
creatures per or whatever I don't know
they can travel like you have the 1200
times or something yeah they can travel
like 1200 times their body in a second
or some [ __ ] but they're so tiny
legendary that's the best yeah you can't
see them until they have all your blood
huh it's just nasty
[ __ ] it's like a dummy
no it's just light oh okay hide your
face sorry but
including the written test if you do the
video because the way they cheat is
insane tendon's setting up the mirrors
in the ceiling somehow oh I guess that
could be interesting for y'all I think
the test plus The Forest Part and then
we should be good should we could be
good are we gonna write that down have
Dom write that part down are we actually
going to get the world right down Naruto
and we'll see most of these are probably
gonna have to do by next year 1010 was
trans
all of their cheating was trash honestly
the way they cheat are super [ __ ]
dumb like they try to do it too hard
right and no one wasn't enough well
Sasuke just did the freaking just I I
analyze their body movements and then I
can just no he's going on and then he
just copied someone else's body yeah
that exactly yeah yeah
it's like but what if he's wrong uh then
now your ass doesn't get a barrel you
know I was like no the thing is the test
was so dumb because the uh I think
question 20 is it's like do you want to
continue or not
and the test the rest of the test
doesn't matter
it's [ __ ] I'll be right right back I
now have to go to the little Griff room
I'll be back I'll be back let's talk to
you about Griffin all right
this [ __ ] voice box man
I think it's so cool how like all y'all
are around the world I saw like
it's actually South Africa parks of us
all this [ __ ] that's [ __ ] cool guy
[ __ ] cool weebs
and a cool Bobcat it's cool I like I
like all our weebs I like all our fans
if they call us our fans I hope they uh
I like to call you guys my minions
that's cooler
wait where is where is where's NC North
Carolina oh okay
where's Virginia man mama
damn here
North Carolina
it's just hot they have good Texas
barbecue that's what I hear
and all the screamers are there or
something
all the problematic streams are there
yes
[Laughter]
West Virginia uh we got poverty and drug
problems ain't that America's problem am
I right
shots fired bro
[Music]
you guys got to come to a mango town
it's hot here all the time and it's
humid too
like you don't want to catch me wearing
the suit out in public like it's too hot
yeah you never get really winners over
there right not really I think um last
year or a couple of years ago it went
down to um you gotta do that conversion
it went down to like 25 degrees Celsius
or 26 in Thailand bro that's like never
happened
but like shut down schools or something
people were like wearing like little
coats and stuff and I was like damn like
do I need a jacket today what's going on
whole thing
yeah
Global trust me we have that here too I
think West Virginia is the Met capital
of America no that's uh New Mexico
Albuquerque uh
Breaking Bad reference them I think so
yeah I I think that's the only thing I
know about breaking bad that's in
Albuquerque
I've never seen the show Good show it's
a good show I need to watch it people
say it's really good uh and also uh
Breaking Bad
is also really good
yes I haven't seen them oh daily life of
an immortal King seeing that kind of if
you haven't have you seen that Al that's
is that another isek hi uh not
I don't think it is it's basic but the
character is overpowered like stupid
overpowered he's basically a God and he
has to restrain his powers it's more of
a comedy thing so that's kind of where
the the hook gets you
um I thought it was pretty good I like
your shots thank you which one are you
talking about it's a Griffith is it mine
of course
wow
is it done which one are we talking
about okay that's very true oh we should
do a poll who likes which shirt do they
like the most that'd be fun
um let's see here
one mouth year old can kill a god I'm
talking about I'm a confused they've
been talking about Naruto Braxton
uh would you guys uh make a how to beat
Midori 1992. I need to look it up again
yeah you do the lookie-uppy
would you rather do hypothermia or heat
ah well I would probably it depends if
what you're saying where are we gonna
like just die by hypothermia or heat I
probably would do
if it's stupid hot I probably would do
heat we might not honestly I just saw
the first one Midori Midori 1992. IMDb
we might not do it you're right I'm
looking it up
mid Dory describe it in Vivid detail
Griff no
no 1992. talk about it wait let me
Google
let's chill out guys let me look at it
first oh
okay
um I see what you're talking about
[Music]
it's a bit cursed I'll read the ah I'll
read the I'll read it for you guys
sorry I don't think we can say that word
here it's a story based of uh
controversial manga by Mario that takes
place
a free show circus group whose members
there's some stuff and she then found a
glimmer of hope in an enigmatic magician
who joins the group all right it's nope
nope we'll talk about it nope no this is
how we get up this is how we'll get uh
This Is How we'll die it's making me
feel like as if it's summer when it's
freaking cold here yeah my guy
you know like uh the will y'all kill
Goku I've been getting I've been getting
so much so into
uh like oversized t-shirts and I've been
into it
it's like a Hawaiian look I don't know
I've been really getting into um
oversized uh t-shirts recently to like
hide my small arms so like it's pretty
good it's working out pretty nice
shirt that he's wearing right now she's
trying to make himself look jacked
that's why I wear long sleeve most of
the time
one day I won't have to hopefully I mean
you're pretty tall so your your biceps
and everything are very long right so
you have to do a lot yeah people say I
have a really big uh
uh what is the part of the leg uh yeah
not calves every big calves uh you sure
freaking do you do it's you got like
you've seen it right it's like I don't
know why it had I've been trying to
figure out and I've been asking people
my cats are huge and like what the [ __ ]
is going on he's got like y'all don't
understand he has naturally built
they're just there and it's like wow
he's got freaking Diamond calves I'll
tell you what
yeah and if you and if you give us a
hundred bucks I'll show it on screen
no no goodness
stick Cavs
uh it'll be if it if we ever hit a
million I'll show my cows I'll get a
tattoo on my calves
that would be [ __ ] funny bro actually
okay that's we're holding you to that
one million tattoo on cabs I don't know
what tattoo I'll think about it nice
nice
it's got to be something cool
see that's true Bobcat I'm not even a
muscle I don't know Griffin's the muscle
guy he's the [ __ ] no I when I first
met him because he's wearing like a and
I only saw his head I thought you were
like oh it's kind of like a scrawny
nerdy good nerdy dude and then you did
that sponsor that he did it's like holy
[ __ ] Griffin's jacked as [ __ ] it's like
what the [ __ ] sponsors uh
because they needed uh help with uh for
filming and stuff it's like I think
Grandma's like holy [ __ ] Grandma's
jacked it's like what the [ __ ]
really not that jacked I'm just a little
it's pretty Japanese
yeah
at work if they weren't teaching you
about the body no it's not how to beat
sales at work it's how to beat what's
that [ __ ] movie where uh
Osmosis Jones how to beat osmosis
a good one that is a good one oh that's
funny that's that's good remember the
villain when he's like he like he kills
the one bacteria or something like
careful I'm contagious and he's got like
glowing dagger finger thing
um
yeah it's because
Murray was the yeah it was he was yes
they moved them to a kid because they
weren't able to pay people
I think that's what happened
uh I've heard Bill Murray is actually
super nice to fans but he's actually
like really mean sometimes depending
like you have a good Bill Murray and a
bad Bill Murray depending on Adam nice
to fans
you guys um you guys like piano weaves
right oh yeah
you know why you like him
I'm like uh how do you how to beat
school I'm not gonna ignore it
Alexander you like him because he's a
lefty I'm sorry weeps ahead uh when he
says left to humans left-handed oh yeah
right
niacan I feel you're paying Dom I'm six
two and only 160. I need to gain about
40 pounds and I just can't
bruh yeah I mean if you're the liver
King you could just spend ten thousand
dollars in steroids and get a turtle
six-pack
dude early before this whole thing
started we were talking about the liver
the liver King and his uh steroids abuse
there it's fifteen thousand dollars
no dumb uh let me and then you can go on
this tangent I'm gonna go yeah a little
bit Yeah has the same problem as one of
my good friends all right uh he says a
phrase that he probably probably didn't
think about and then he kept doing it oh
he's the Lefty he's I have a friend
who's like he's not even that chubby
he's like a very like he's very fit uh
don't remember Toto uh yeah he's a very
fit dude well and then whenever we hang
out he always says to me he's like oh my
God you can see my job but he met he met
his gut his stomach a little bit and how
to correct him every time bro don't say
it in front of people
they're gonna
God damn it uh and then after a while
and then I he literally didn't believe
me because he's like no bro shut the
[ __ ] up it's like you're not like you
like I have to get through or something
yeah I have to Google uh Urban
Dictionary to show it oh my God
you know what you should look up uh it's
disgusting it's called from under cheese
urban dictionary for Monday
just look it up just look at it up
Bob he's not gonna tell you where he is
in Thailand shut the [ __ ] up Burger Shot
what happened no Burger I'm asking where
are you from well I mean I'm in Bangkok
so you know all right all right look it
up look up from under Cheese look it up
I don't want to real quick wait what am
I looking at under cheese from
fro m-u-n-d-a from Anda it's all one
word cheese Urban Dictionary cheese this
is like some blue waffles
a warm slimy substance that grows on
your own person when you don't shut up
I thought it was there actually coin
purse oh my gosh is a kid's Channel why
usually this covers my sliding it's too
late Ariel it's too late
I thought Griff was wholesome oh that's
something Ariel's like don't you dare
look that up
game okay I mean listen I'm 99 of the
time I'm very nice but there's this one
percent of like dark jokes and and like
stuff like that I'm like oh that's like
I find funny so yeah you'll get matching
kyotats uh I don't want a geotat that
would be cute Ariel I just thought it'd
be fine it is gross as [ __ ] though
uh
oh my cheeks hurt uh I feel like that's
a good place to end it and we can
continue it next week right yeah I think
that sounds good guys I we promise as we
get further into this uh pod thing we're
gonna have some structure to the madness
uh yes yes did you enjoy it did you
enjoy it
this is not a kid's Channel you're right
because it's not a kitchen look at
Silence of guys comment what a thing to
just tune into and hear about
[Laughter]
it's not really a podcast but it's fun
live stream to hang out with you oh this
is fun uh yes or no I'm good I wrote yes
why not oh that's funny
100 yes baby
oh hey
oh that is fun that was real fun it
seems
kintama has been getting a lot of
attention lately kintama's always had a
lot of tension uh if you I glad I waited
for Bobcat to search that thing first
I'm definitely not gonna search
you made me read it
that's funny
Keanu Reeves uh you gotta love the chat
full of memories and weaves God damn
that's right we love you guys
hey Ariel says no structure in this
lovely chaotic place
that's true that's very nice uh Keanu
Reeves yeah I heard about the keanuary
story yeah his life's pretty sad
actually but he's always so happy
yeah
like no I'm saying like he's been
through some [ __ ] but like okay
this is her life
because
when they were younger but it's good
that I think it it shows his character
right that yeah even though a lot of
atrocities happen to you you're still a
good guy Bro Look up the meaning of
Gintama okay I will
done
isn't it like balls
oh God Global Gabby stay in school but
we appreciate you not doing your college
I'm supposed to do college work what are
you what are you studying Global Gabby
Global oh my gosh yeah what is it what
is it what is it uh okay Gintama means
silver and then balls Thomas silver
balls
yeah if I remember correctly there was a
there was a Japanese folklore you can
get kintama which is Akin is uh Golden
Balls
you know there's a focus wait wasn't
there raccoons Tanuki I can't remember
it's been a while
wasn't there a thing now was it on Tick
Tock where like dudes were like dip
their you know the jewels and something
to see if they could taste something
like the flavor of something I thought
that was a thing there was a thing on
Tick Tock actually I hope that's never a
thing ah no I think that was actually a
thing people they like test it out I
mean they never showed actually I'm
doing but they like filmed themselves
like from the waist up like wait
speaking of jewels uh which video okay
experience don't forget to sponsor us
Jewel pots cucumber whatever no what was
that what was the the vid with the
manscape thing where I talked about
jewels and like now it's been a while
bro I can't remember oh geez that was
good [ __ ] good [ __ ] shoot what was that
one uh you guys are awesome amazing oh
you're gonna be a teacher good for you
oh look Abby nice all right we need more
teachers there's a lot of really [ __ ]
teachers around there's and we're I
isn't America has an outage of teachers
though
depends on each state yeah it depends I
hear a lot of like stuff in on Tick Tock
or on YouTube shorts yeah it really
depends on the state some teachers
unions are like super like just I don't
know what's the word to say other than
just
they need to kind of clicky like very
clicky you know
but yeah but it's always good that
people want to be teachers and I I hope
you uh continue or gotta teach these
damn kids some manners these days you
know
you really want people to turn on like
dumb
with a favorite show being Johnny Bravo
is that what you want you're right
that's right I don't want a Bravo
oh my goodness who said something like
that I saw something I won't forget to
watch unicorn next time I won't forget
you better all right I love to chat
thank you guys for coming by yes thank
you so much guys like subscribe comment
uh watch our stuff we're gonna continue
to come up because Griffin already
spoiled it what don't say it well they
already moved start people know yeah at
the beginning in the beginning they
might not know yet all right I'm gonna
say it anyway we're gonna do parasite
part two
uh if you guys haven't seen it you guys
watched the first one that'd be sick
that was a good [ __ ] good [ __ ] uh we're
gonna finish out parasite part two and
then we're gonna do something fun the
next week that you're probably really
gonna like uh but you guys gotta go uh
we're so much fun uh all right uh thank
you I'll see you guys
Ariel Burger Shot thank you guys so much
everyone for coming and uh we'll catch
you on the next one we're gonna do this
one guys come on for sure and just a
reminder everyone guys aldam this is
gonna be the regular thing right
Thursdays is gonna be the time right
pause putting in my calendar Braxton I
got you bro yay bye-bye bye guys